account for the rise of services such as
Siri and Google now in your heads I'll
make reference to relevant database
communication and hardware systems now
quick tip right as in the HSE and the
exams I right right whenever you see
something like in your answer make
reference to you've really got to make
specific reference to those items okay
if you don't and that should be fine but
you're really going to cheat yourself
right so let's go through them one by
one let's go to database services okay
how does Siri and Google now do their
thing how they actually adding value to
the user experience well whoo here we go
that's there okay um you're getting
intelligence out of Siri or Google now
right bayi being able to get sue Syrian
Google right can get to all these
different kinds of databases right so
examples are maps that's a kind of
database where the reports that's a kind
of database website listings Google is a
giant database of website listing right
up-to-date sports of flight details now
QC these here right these are the
specific databases relevant database
systems that are being referred to
that's how Syrian google now doing their
thing these are the databases okay now
some of you you just said it mate
they've accessed databases and you
didn't tell me anything about the kinds
of databases right so automatically yeah
you know you haven't given me anything
passport in the question does that make
sense those are you all the
communications right so that's in here
you're getting by my OTA over-the-air so
that's that is wireless cellular data
which is really efficient right because
it's not stored on your device right
you're being able to get things from you
know wherever Google stores it adds up
to date all the time so that's why it
can be relevant and timely because being
delivered to you constantly right does
that make sense so that's what brings in
communication systems yep yep okay um so
you see here's my point here right that
if you're of god you're trying to
provide a service to users which can
allow them to ask anything right
anything think about how much
local storage you'd require on your
device if it was able to store all the
answers to any questions you can ask on
here right it would be enormous right so
that's why we use communication systems
in order to bridge that gap we can't
start on your advice but we can sort out
our gigantic servers in the US or
wherever and get you to access them
remotely okay does that make sense so I
mean these data centers that distributed
internationally all these different toes
are all over the place so that's why
these communication systems had to
become widespread before Syrian Google
now could come up right now that also
relates to the fact that look at the
question carefully right it says account
for the rise of these services account
for the rise of these services so what
that means is look these services these
services are now available and they're
really good they're quite high quality
how can that be right so I'm providing
you the reasons for how that took place
I'm not saying look he's Syrian Google
now and here's what they can do right so
I'm accounting for the rise of these
services I'm not telling you okay now
that these services are here already
what can they do okay so a lot of you
you've seen my academic in a cube right
that means you didn't answer the
question because you've missed what me
account from the rise okay lastly right
particular hardware services right so
what does a phone have to be able to do
to be able to get to Syrian Google down
and make it work right the main process
that I was interested in was faster
processing right so things like language
recognition being able to talk to Siri
or Google now and have it really
understand what you say within reason
right that requires serious competing
power but that wasn't possible in the
smartphones of 10 years ago partly
because 10 years ago smartphones we're
not very smart right so that's a recent
hardware advance that makes it possible
right if Syria and Google now the
designers have come at ten years ago and
said we've got this great idea give me
just talking to their phones and it'll
send the question over and we'll you
know do that kind of thing let's say we
can't do this are you crazy you're only
super computers can do that kind of
thing
you can't feel one of those in someone's
pocket right so these recent hardware
advances make Syrian google now possible
does that make sense do you see how I'm
answering the question yeah okay so the
four marks where do they go roughly
speaking I had one for each section and
that last mark was for how will you
actually answer the question like they
were just separate piece of information
can you see how they all relate to the
question well okay I always made it
three marks and then when I wrote my own
answers to this I thought wow that's a
lot of work that's a lot of thinking
right so that's where the fourth Mark
comes in that's where i was going to pay
ok any questions